Dodgeball on trampolines?
An asparagus pile is a great way
to hide a cake.
Vsauce, Kevin here—
this is Mind Blow.
This stainless steel mechanical ring clock
is a concept
that tells the time
down to the second,
with the current time being highlighted
along the individually-rotating rings.
And it will probably fit well
on this bionic hand.
Matthew James sent a letter
asking for a new hand,
and Mercedes said, "Okay."
It has two electrodes
inside the socket
that detect electrical impulses
made by the muscles of his lower arm.
The signals are then beamed
to a mini-computer in the palm,
which translates the messages
into movements.
The movements of this robot head
are dependent
upon the music
that it reads.
The cameras in the eyes
read sheet music,
then an algorithm translates
the pitch
and the vocalizer sings it,
like this.
[♪ robot singing ♪]
Electronics and human skin collide
with these skin patches,
designed to monitor vital signs
without invasive wires.
It physically connects you
to the cyberworld
in a way that feels natural
and comfortable,
almost like a temporary tattoo.
The iTabulus is a 40-inch display
converted into a giant iPhone,
just in case you ever wanted
a coffee table that plays Angry Birds.
If you want your eyeballs
to sparkle,
just wear diamond contact lenses.
18 diamonds are studded
in a circular manner
on an 18 carat gold device
attached to the back of the lenses
that does not touch the cornea
and costs around $16,000 dollars a pair.
Old man brushing his beard
with a fork on the subway.
This prize-winning 3D system
is built
with a four-sided glass enclosure,
which displays the four sides of the object.
It scans the object on a turntable
and reproduces it
with four projectors,
so you can physically walk around it
and see all sides.
Now, for the ballet
of the bulbs.
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
Finally, here's
a video game dance party
called "What Your Games Do
Behind Your Back."
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
I'm going to leave you with a riddle.
[I can sizzle like bacon. I'm made with an egg.]
[I have plenty of backbone but lack a good leg.]
[I peel layers like onions but still remain whole.]
[I can be long like a flagpole, yet fit in a hole.]
[Subscribe]
[Vsauce]
[Mind Blow Genius of the Week: sehoxpirth]
My life can be measured in hours;
I serve by being devoured.
Thin, I am quick;
fat, I am slow.
Wind is my foe.
What am I?
There are eight video game references
in this video.
The first person to name them all
will be our genius of the week.
So good luck, and as always,
thanks for watching.
[Vsauce 2]
[Subscribe]
[Ultimate Snack Pizza]
[♪ music ♪]